hey everyone I'm Alanna Oh Cheryl on
Azad and today I'm talking you guys
about the idea that video games are
antisocial I've never understood this
massive misconception because video
games are by far the most social thing I
do well social then tumblr most social
the Twitter more social than Facebook
and those are social networking websites
when I'm at a friend's house or I've
just been out drinking there's nothing
that I like more than to come home and
play Halo until the Sun rises
we love WeChat strategies we talk about
completely unrelated things to the game
but we still that working towards this
active goal together and playing
actually have very little recollection
of what I did before I started playing
games with people or if there ever was
anything that I did to people just watch
reruns of friends or movies in silence
until they eventually fall asleep even
watching something because you actually
have to actively listen to the noise
rather than when you're playing a game
you don't really need to listen to the
dialogue quite as much it seems
significantly less social than gaming
even if you're with a group of people I
think what it is is the video games are
considered antisocial because when
you're playing a game you will
ultimately by yourself however this is
the exact same as watching TV or being
on Facebook or being on tumblr the only
major difference there is that Tumblr
and Facebook seem to be used more for
observations than for actual discussions
this is me on Facebook you're a wanker
there's a meme wow I know the wanker
that's really racist
I'm pretty sure I'm not alone on that
one where you don't actually interact
with people that much and most of what
you do is just observe but then again
people are like a bit Facebook in social
network it's social media so is Xbox
LIVE books on social media but I can't
say I've actually heard someone say that
books are antisocial and that they are
bad for your social skill I just don't
think they should bad enough people for
playing video games as something that's
anti-social when it is actually designed
to be one of the most social
technologies in existence some people
are antisocial people these people may
play video games and not to talk to
anyone else but that's not the fault of
the video game
an antisocial person would also watch TV
shows by themselves and not talk to
anyone or read books by themselves and
not talk to anyone or play guitar by
themselves and not talk to anyone these
things are the characteristics of an
antisocial person not that video games
themselves are antisocial because that's
ridiculous not to mention there's this a
normal thriving community that has come
out of the existence of video games we
have V we have our gaming we have these
massive forums where people just go to
talk to each other about video games
online quite regularly I don't know it's
just one of these things it seems like a
dumb stereotype that I could never
really wrap my head around but that's it
for me today you guys I will see you
guys next time bye bye